Have you ever thought of launching your
own podcast or interview series, but you
don't really know where to get started?
Over the past five years, I've had the
opportunity to host more than 250
podcast episodes across five different
podcasts in a wide variety of themes and
genres from public speaking to real
estate to cryptocurrency and blockchain
technology. and not only shooting those
podcast episodes, but also editing them,
figuring out distribution. I've learned
a lot throughout my time doing that. And
on this video, I am going to share the
seven best tips I have for anyone who is
thinking of launching a podcast.
Whenever my friends ask me for my
advice, these are the things I share
with them. If you're thinking of
launching a podcast and your early
indication is to make it audio only, I
actually suggest you rethink that and
include the element of video. If you're
going to all the work of creating a
podcast episode and potentially bringing
a guest on to interview him or her, that
is a lot of effort. And you could have
an amazing audio experience podcast, but
you're sort of limiting it to that
single medium because when you add the
element of video, now you can post that
content on YouTube. And yes, I
understand some audio only podcasts
still create a YouTube video with just
the audio and maybe an image, but let's
face it, that is not as interesting
content to consume on YouTube. And
YouTube is a massive search engine, so
people can discover your content. But
the other big benefit is the clips of
the special moments from the episode
that you can share. And just like this
video I'm creating, I will take several
clips from it and I will share it in
places like Instagram reels, Tik Tok,
YouTube shorts, etc. And so now, because
you have video, you're distributing this
content in several different places, and
it gives you a far higher likelihood
that people will come across your
podcast and your great content. If
you're thinking of launching a podcast,
it's a great idea to include interviews.
Not only are interview guests
interesting and can bring a different
perspective other than you or your
co-hosts, but it actually helps you with
discoverability.
Because if you bring on a guest to your
podcast, often that guest will be more
than happy to share out the episode and
potentially the clips that you have from
that conversation to their social media
platforms. And so if you start to do the
math, as soon as you do 10, 20, 30
episodes, not only is that the content
from your own podcast or channel that
has the opportunity to be discovered on
various platforms, but now you've taken
10, 20, 30 other individuals who are
going to help distribute that content
for you in front of their audiences who
might be completely different than the
audiences who are discovering your
channel on their own. This really helps
speed up successful podcasts and ensure
that more and more eyeballs get on it.
And here's a bonus tip. Don't be afraid
to ask big named guests on your show.
What's the worst that can happen? They
say no. That's okay. What if one of them
says yes? What if one of them with a
100,000, 200,000, a million followers
says yes because they like what you're
doing on your podcast? That is a really
big accelerator in terms of the number
of people who could see your content. So
consider interviewing people because
that could help your podcast grow
quicker. If you decide you're going to
launch a podcast or interview series and
you've started to invite guests to come
on your show, I strongly suggest you do
your research prior to interviewing
them. There is a pet peeve I have and it
is so common on podcasts. I'm going to
throw out a random guess of a statistic
that I bet 80% of podcasts start like
this. And the next time you listen to a
podcast, especially not a very popular
one, maybe a lower tier, I bet the host
starts the interview by perhaps
introducing the guest and then saying,
"Hey, Bill, for those who don't know
you, can you give a brief description of
yourself? [snorts] Can you introduce
yourself?" This is so common that hosts
ask the guest to introduce themsel. And
I think that's a wasted opportunity. one
because now your interview is starting
exactly how so many other interviews
have started that the guest has been on,
but also it comes across as a little bit
lazy, a missed opportunity. What's much
better is if you do the research and you
can read a bio or an intro that
introduces the guest to the audience
that's listening or watching your
content. And then start off with that
first question, not by asking them to
introduce themselves, but by asking
something that is really smart and is
going to catch their attention and a
question that has never been asked to
them before, at least as the first
question on an interview.
If you do that right away, you're
setting the tone. The guest will
probably say, "Wow, like what an intro.
What a good question. I've never been
asked that before." That for your
audience confirms to them that they are
listening to or watching great content
and that you are a great interviewer,
but it's going to excite your guest as
well. It's going to make them
be interested in where's this
conversation going to go. This is going
to be a lot of fun. questions I love
asking if somebody has built a
successful career in something, asking,
"Hey, when you were eight-year-old
Shawn, did you ever imagine that you
would be doing this as a career? What
were your earliest ambitions?"
The other thing I love is when you're
able to note something, doing your
research. So, I I find listening to
other podcasts that the guest has been
on is really powerful for this. So, if
you listen to another interview and
maybe it's minute 43 of that interview
where the guest says something that
catches your attention and maybe you
notice the host of that interview
doesn't ask a follow-up question, but
you can weave that into your interview
and the guest will think, "How did this
person know that about me?" The best
interview hosts know this. They know
that powerful questions that are not
typically asked of the guests are most
likely to result in a great interview.
One thing many people underestimate when
they go to launch their first podcast is
how important it is to have good audio.
And I don't care if it's an audio only
podcast or a video and audio podcast.
Audio is so incredibly important. After
watching back the recording that I shot
in my car, I wanted to shoot a quick
clip so you could hear the difference of
what great audio sounds like with a
podcast mic. This is a sure mic. I also
like Audio Technica. And if you have a
podcast, the audience wants to have a
clean listening experience.
And if your audio as the host isn't
great, it's going to be off-putting from
wanting to listen to that episode. And
the best example I ever heard of this is
the fact that people will be forgiving
if the host's audio is good, but the
guests audio isn't maybe the same
quality. And think about a radio DJ who
has that clean microphone and then
people are phoning in talking on their
phones. The audio isn't the same quality
from them, but people are used to the
host audio being good. So, it might be
worthwhile to you don't have to pay all
sorts of money to have a really really
professional microphone, but maybe you
kind of do a step up compared to what
some people would use so that that audio
is sounding clean and it is enjoyable
for anyone who is checking out your
podcast. If you're going to launch a
podcast, you might want to do some
thinking about the purpose of it. Who is
the intended audience? What do you hope
they take away from these episodes? Is
there going to be a certain structure?
Do you maybe chat with your co-host
before bringing the guest in? Do you ask
every guest the same series of
questions, which can create some
interesting secondary clip content
opportunities when you do that, right?
What is going to be the general
structure and why? Why are you doing it?
And if your reason for launching a
podcast is that you want to make money,
I suggest you find another reason. There
was a quote by Logan Paul a while ago
and he was giving advice to somebody who
was interested in launching a podcast or
YouTube content and they were saying
they want to make money and Logan
laughed at him and said, "You have to
plan to do this for 10 years and not
make a penny." And that's what I would
suggest. Even if you do a podcast for
five years, you may lose more money on
equipment and if you hire an editor,
like [snorts] there are costs associated
with it and it takes a while to build up
an audience and build up monetization.
And sure, some podcasters over time do
incredible and then they make all sorts
of money, but I promise you the best
ones aren't setting out at the beginning
for that sole reason. They have a bigger
why. there's a reason they want to be
doing this content. And when your why is
bigger, that's what's going to drive you
and motivate you to put out these
episodes on a consistent basis. So
that's the important piece is to
understand what the purpose is behind
your podcast before you even launch it.
Another thing you might want to think
about if you're going to launch a
podcast is what is the cadence going to
be? How many episodes do you plan to put
out? and in what frequency.
And be realistic because podcasts do
take effort, especially ones that are
high quality. And so if you come out and
you're like, I'm going to post a podcast
twice a week, that's a tremendous amount
of work. So, you should be really aware
and realistic about the goal and
something that you can stick to because
consistency is often rewarded on social
media platforms as well as audio
platforms like Spotify and YouTube. The
platforms like when the creators are
posting consistently. So, what does
consistent look like for you and what is
realistic? And then what you can
consider doing is have a few episodes as
backups. So on the shelf because you
don't always want to be relying that
okay I release episodes every Friday and
I shoot them every Tuesday. What if
something comes up? What if there's an
emergency? What if you get sick? What if
you are not able to record that content?
That's the nice thing about having a few
episodes in the can on the shelf.
Whatever the phrase is, but have them
ready to go as backups. That way you
always have a little bit of a buffer if
you're not able to record for a couple
of weeks. But think about your cadence
before you go and set out to launch a
podcast. The final tip I have for
launching a podcast is that it does not
have to be perfect on day one. Often
people put this pressure on themselves
and it's a big reason why they don't
ever take action because they think
their podcast has to be completely
dialed at the very beginning. And sure,
there are things you can set out to do,
such as creating great audio and having
a good idea and maybe do research on the
guests that you're going to be
interviewing.
But go to any of your favorite
podcasters first episode and their
earliest content and you are not going
to see the polished episodes that
they're putting out today because
everyone has to start somewhere. And so
for you to think that your chapter 1 is
the same as somebody else's chapter 43
is ludicrous. It doesn't make any sense.
It's much better to start to learn to
experience and then to try to have
incremental growth where you make each
episode just a little bit better. That
is going to be the best way versus
sitting on the sidelines and thinking,
"Hey, I'll start the podcast when I'm
totally ready and I have everything
figured out." the high likelihood of
what will happen there is you will just
never do the podcast. So, don't be
scared to get started. I hope this video
has been helpful for giving you some
ideas and perhaps some inspiration for
starting your own podcast journey. For
me, it's been a blast. I've really
enjoyed the 250 plus episodes that I've
had the chance to create over the last
five years and I will continue to put
out podcast content because it brings me
joy in speaking about things I'm
passionate about. If this is something
you want to dive deeper with me
oneon-one and customize this advice for
your podcast, I have a link in the video
description for my standtore and there
is an opportunity for you to do some
podcast coaching with me one- on-one. I
can hear your idea, understand what your
vision is, and then give you some really
great suggestions to ensure you have as
much success as possible right out of
the gate. So check that out if you're
interested. Otherwise, check out the
video that's popping up on the screen
right now, which is being recommended
for you. And if you have not already
subscribed to my channel, if you don't
know, I'm all about impactful
communication. I want to help you be a
better communicator. Whether that's
podcasting, public speaking, social
media thoughts, this is what drives me.
This is what I'm passionate about. and
it would mean a lot you would support my
channel by subscribing.